[Applause]
well let me tell you straight away that
uh stephen actually then or tommy
robinson he calls himself has been
sentenced to
nine months in prison for contempt of
court
uh it has been the senate has been
reduced slightly because of time spent
already in custody remember this is
something that he was convicted of
last year at leeds crown court he had
been filming
defendants uh in a trial for a
pedophilia for a grooming trial
uh there were a series of trials taking
place so there were reporting
restrictions in place
so that uh the details of each
individual case
weren't being broadcast uh to the public
but uh he carried on filming outside he
was immediately arrested
brought before the court and within five
hours he had been sentenced to ten
months in prison plus another
three months for a previous offense for
which you've been given a suspended
sentence now that was
overturned on appeal because justice was
seen to be so
uh swift on that particular occasion so
there was a retrial
uh demanded by the attorney general uh
he had a two-day hearing
here at the old bailey last week in
front of two high court judges they
convicted him last week and just to
remind you they have now sentenced him
to nine months uh in jail although he'll
spend less time than that
because of the three months that he
already served tommy robinson uh was
expecting to go to prison it should be
said because on
uh three days ago he appeared on an
american
internet broadcast in which he feared he
said he feared going to jail he feared
that it was a
death sentence as he put it because he
feared he would be attacked
and killed inside prison so he asked for
political asylum but that was not
forthcoming from anyone in the united
states authorities
so he arrived at court today at around
about 25
past nine he was due in court in the
dock
at half past nine so he was leaving it
rather late and he took his time coming
up the street because
there were hundreds of protesters now
those protesters are gathered behind me
they had moved away from the
port building about an hour ago and
moved to the end of the road for
um a bit of a rally that was taking
place the bus had been placed there
gerald baton the former eucalypt leader
was among those who was addressed who
was addressing the crowd but word is
obviously filtering through now
what has happened to stephen jackson
lennon or tommy robinson who has now
been
sentenced to nine months in jail
otherwise they say he'll serve a little
less than that
because of the time he served in prison
last year